[Musique]
oh [
Musique]
s'il te plaît, fais-le dans toutes les directions
[Musique]
qui sait s'il va y avoir une
différence dans ce monde qui sait si
ce sera la dernière fois que nous nous
réunirons tous dans quelque chose comme ça
donc nous ne faisons que protester pacifiquement,
nous n'allons pas continuer à
emmener la police tuer des Noirs
sans raison, la circulation s'arrête,
vous connaissez les problèmes de santé mentale, c'est donc
juste la façon dont nous avons appris à
être solidaires et à montrer que nous sommes  tu
ne vas pas
savoir que nous défendons une cause
en attendant nous appelons à la paix
et au calme
et nous devrions écouter euh la mère de dante
qui appelle à la paix et au calme
[Musique]
oh
étranger